historiquement la pratique vient du pays
du soleil levant ses fourneaux mais
anagama sont d'origine japonaise mais
c'est bien ici qu'a été construit le
premier four à bois occidental à
l'intérieur le phare dans peut cuire
jusqu'à 3 mètres cubes de poterie soit
environ 350 petits bols qu'ils puissent
pendant près de six jours sans arrêt à
environ 1300 degrés lucien petit et
sculpteurs céramistes et c'est avec
passion qui perpétue cette tradition
pour cuire toutes les céramiques qui
sont à l'intérieur qui peuvent être des
objets utilitaires comme des oeuvres
d'art
tout simplement et ça c'est très
important quand même c'est c'est une
approche de la culture et ça sert
vraiment à quelque chose surtout par les
temps qui courent ben quand on voit
toutes ses montées de fascisme de
populisme la culture dans notre planète
entière
je pense c'est important de parler de
culture et d'affirmer la culture une
fois cuites certaines pièces se retrouve
au centre de céramique contemporaine
à l'époque la céramique et est utilisé
pour la production d'ustensiles de
cuisine et pour la conservation des
aliments
aujourd'hui la cuisson unique dufour est
recherché par de nombreux artistes
c'est d'ailleurs l'intérêt de la cuisson
au bois c'est qu'il ya quand même une
une action de la cuisson sur la qualité
de la pièce finale ça rajoute un côté un
côté unique à une pièce puisque
effectivement c'est laisser le four
c'est la flamme c'est la cendre qui vont
faire le travail
toute cette partie là en fait on voit
bien que la texture est complètement
lisse et elle a été obtenue par la
vitrification des cendres qui ce sens
déposés sur la pièce ses oeuvres d'art
sont majoritairement pendu aux états
unis elles coûtent des milliers d'euros
et à défaut de pouvoir sur les offrir
vous pouvez venir les découvrir à la
borne jusqu'au 3 novembre